you Kip the party that many credit were
delivering the brexit referendum but
what happens when Nigel Farage one of
the most charismatic political leaders
in recent times leaves to start a new
movement based on the same idea Jared
Burton the party's new leader believes
the government's failure to deliver on
brexit will give you Kip a boost in the
polls but the figure of mr. Faraj looms
large if you think I'm standing aside
for somebody on this personal ego trip
I'm afraid the leap the voters can
forget it they've got to make a choice
between a real party or phony party Mr
Farage has warned that his Old Party has
become loutish he's wrong about UK he's
wrong about what you Kipp is now we're
not far-right thumbs up fairness I can't
underpricing a barrister I'm a highly
respected pillar of society I'm not
covered in tattoos but new candidates
have left the leader with questions to
answer one Carl Benjamin tweeted a
controversial comments about rape you
said it was a satirical comment what did
you mean by that well let's go and ask
Col Benjamin this is a three-year-old
tweet that he did in the context of some
Twitter trolling them what people were
doing because he remains a you keep
candidate and you certainly does an L
ill-considered remark and if you were
going to stop people taking part in
public life or anything else because of
some stupid ill-considered remark of
several years before then I don't think
you'd have anybody in Parliament or
anywhere else in public life that kind
of comment though has prompted some come
ask me the question how many times are
you going to ask me the same question
thank you very much
so what will voters in the party's
heartland like Thanet make of you Kip
you Kip says it offers more than just
brexit but the party's EU election
slogan tell them again focused on that
vote and questions about new candidates
just wouldn't go away I asked you
earlier on today about your decision to
defend your candidate and his suggestion
that he wouldn't even rate
and I would like to ask Carl Benjamin
why you think it is acceptable to say on
Twitter that you wouldn't even rape a
female labor because I don't think when
there are any difference to man in the
way to treatment unlike the
establishment unlike our judges who
literally say if you were a man I was
sent you to jail I think you should
treat women the same as men and that
means if a woman is being a giant
laughing the male suicide I'm gonna be a
drink back to you
any questions there's no doubt that a
party pledging to get on with brexit
will win votes the question is is you
kept still the clear choice Kate McCann
Sky News